first of all
big fan of both of your work uh great to
be able to talk with you today
uh i wanted to start with a question not
about the movie uh
what did you both feel in your career
that you had made it enough as an actor
that you could do that for a living and
pay rent
i actually feel it was pretty definitive
because
whether i was right about it or not um i
um when i did troop beverly hills um i
was 16
and i lied and said that i was 14 to get
the job
and it's the only time if you ever see a
picture of me with the other
troop girls i'm taller i'll never be
taller than any animal
i was actually two years older um and i
do remember though that movie very
clearly
was enough money that it meant that i
didn't have to go home to finish my last
year of high school and that i was going
to be able to finish it
in los angeles while i kept acting which
was a very
significant moment for me um so i went
through
hard times after that in terms of ups
and downs of career making money as
actors do um but it was
that moment really did make me think i
think i can be
um a professional actor and uh yeah so
it was very defining
yeah i think uh once i got that that
first job you know and i could let go of
the survival gig
you know which was answering phones you
know booking facials
and that was maybe about a long 10
months after graduating from drama
school
and uh and and only having maybe like a
lunch break of 45 minutes to
catch a train across town downtown to
run into an audition to try to make an
impression
then get back to work to answer those
phones be able to pay that rent
but once i got that first gig which was
a play a bus
a bus and truck tour um with the negro
ensemble company
um there was no turning back and uh you
know after that you just
kept acting and if there was a lull
there was always an unemployment
i appreciate you guys uh indulging that
question um
uh one of the things about this film is
when you guys make an action movie it's
always
you guys surrounded by men what i loved
about this it's a bunch of
women kicking ass together i'm assuming
that was the draw for the script and
story of what
pulled you guys in definitely that's a
part of it but it's a lot of ingredients
that go into
uh you know you know a couple
ingredients that go into making a great
milkshake
so you know it's the script it's the
director and his vision
it's the other castmates that you get an
opportunity to play with and
then it you know and it's the role is it
something different you know different
than
any experience that you've had before
perhaps that will like challenge you and
and grow you
um so all of this had all of that going
going for it it was such a uh cool thing
to see
all these women being assembled and uh
and feeling like
because a lot of us actually hadn't met
each other so
it was also cool to see to know that we
were going to kind of
team up with for me with women that
whose work i have respected
and loved watching and and that doesn't
always mean that you're going to be
sympatico
you know means that you'll come and
deliver and be professionals
but we ended up all from the moment we
were all on set together it was like a
natural fit
and and the the desire to have fun and
the strong work ethic and everything was
was there so it was a really cool combo
if you guys could bring
a previous character you've played as
another character in the library with
you
which character would it be and why i
guess for me it would probably be ingrid
cortez it would probably
be mom and spy kids um because she was
super resourceful um uh championed
or her kids and uh was a spy
i think any time you can add a spy into
your scenario it's helpful we need to do
some recon
um she'd be there to do that uh and um
uh yeah like i always i i felt a little
bit like ingrid cortez was like a
a second cousin to madeline
oh well i don't know let me see i was
like who would i
why not bring stella because sometimes
we you know
we need to have a little fun a little
enjoyment
you know a little release you know we're
we've
we're pent up reading all day long and
you know
dewey decimal system but we need to have
a little fun so
let's let's let's bring some music let's
bring some king
let's let's bring some young guys let's
let's have a good time
carla we are all fans of when you uh
team up with mike flanagan
are there any plans of you guys working
together in the future
there are conversations being happening
right now that i cannot say anything
more than that but yes hopefully we will
be teaming up in the near future
uh yes i need that to happen tomorrow
make that happen
just throwing that out there and angela
obviously all of us are
huge fans of mission impossible
franchise and are so looking forward to
the next black panther movie
uh i know you have to be guarded with
what you say but what can you tease
about
mission impossible 7 and black panther 2
i can't tease anything about mission
impossible seven that
except that well kovit took me out
literally or kept me out how about that
you know
um so um yeah that's all i know about
that so maybe i'll be able to tease
eight
when that comes along uh black panther
you know literally getting ready to uh
uh you know get on board for that within
a couple of weeks
we we began that have you read a script
yet
i've read a script but it's changed five
times
it's changed five times and i hear it's
you know
from little notes and emails i
anticipate that it has changed since
then
so all that i've tried to memorize i
probably have to throw that out
my last question about the actual film
by the way thank you um i loved the
library set
you guys have worked on so many
different projects what is it like when
you walk on a set like that that's just
so cool and well done
was that one of your favorite sets that
you've been on absolutely it was it made
your jaw dropped
and how gorgeous it was it was the
specificity of it
it was super helpful um to kind of know
where we lived and
so uh aw inspiring and even down to the
fact that they
drew those amazing lions the the lioness
with her two lions at her side
um which felt so emblematic of the three
librarians and
they really thought it out and it also
felt like it needed to be very
it was an auspicious space you know it
needed to be something that had weight
and history in it
and it's rare when you're on a set
actually maybe the only other thing i
would like into it in terms of
how uh impactful it was for me is the
house in the first haunting
uh because that was on a stage but
generally on stage you kind of feel like
it's a set
when you're in it and this one didn't
feel like that nor did nor did the house
in the haunting
he said it definitely said immediately
yeah and informed your character
thank you so much for your time
congratulations on the movie good luck
with the rest of your
interview thank you so much good to see
you